thank you for joining us this morning
let's hear
a message from mexico has been
working to address the increase in
migratory flows by offering the
option of applying for refugee status by
adapting the legal framework to offer
regional work cards to
those who wish to stay or those who
seek  work in the southern states
of mexico and also increase
migratory control actions to the
southern border of mexico and the isthmus of
tehuantepec without these efforts
the flows of migrants arriving at the
us border could be much
greater
we calculate that a quarter of  million
additional migrants could arrive at
the us border in 2019 without the
efforts that i have just described this
we are going to have time for some
questions from you
the imposition of tariffs
along with the decision to cancel the
aid problems in the
northern countries of  Central America
would surely have a counterproductive effect and not
reduce  migratory flows would
tariffs could cause
financial and economic instability which means
that mexico could reduce its capacity
to deal with migratory flows and
offer alternatives to new
migrants who have recently arrived in
the country
and we can start from the left right
if you want
what the proposal  of gméxico
work together with the us as has been done
and the rest of the international community
particularly with the countries
involved in the transit and origin of
the migratory flow with the ultimate goal
of reducing forced migration forced
by poverty due to violence
and accelerating development  economy and
well-being of salvador guatemala and
honduras
mexico is convinced that only
this this effort will
address the fundamental causes of
migration and will provide a
comprehensive response to the problem
thank you very much chancellor I am going to take a
siesta
tariff is imposed in relation to the
impact  what would you have in agriculture  a
would be in the order of one thousand 410 million
dollars this is approximately 3.8
million dollars a day which would
impact both sides of the
border particularly the consumer
of wii
design
actions together overcome his excess
before he does not want to negotiate that he no longer
wants to speak
his  marine representatives we annexed
without knowing how to leave johnny initiative of
central america between state department we
can forget before sport
2 they
make english goal project
if you think so we go with nationals two
for nationals two for less internal
the first ones would be to resort to
multilateral organizations we know that
this has a  rhythm a
probably less effective rhythm and there is the
matter of retaliation and the carrousel
we are evaluating those possibilities
let's say we are preparing but
we know and trust that diplomacy
that these actions of persuasion and
conviction to work together
to maintain this productive
and commercial integration  work
could not  I would say that they are going to be the same,
otherwise we will have to make a
strategic approach also there
to take into account the many aspects
of this commercial relationship, we do not
want to use tariffs to
damage value chains, we do not want to
use tariffs to damage the creation of
jobs or damage the investment
nothing